MATT PARKER: OK, so it's
a Numberphile video.
We should do something
with numbers.
I've got a blackboard here, so
we'll just bring this up.
The first thing I'd like to do
is show you a very nice, very
quick, wonderful number trick.
Ah, excellent.
Some brown paper.
OK, so for this number trick,
what you do is you take any
one-digit number.
So for example, Brady, what
one digit would you like?
BRADY HARAN: 6.
MATT PARKER: 6.
Lovely number, 6.
So you write down the number
6, that's the digit you
picked, and then you write it
down two more times to get a
three-digit number.
So in this case, 666.
And then what you do is first of
all, you work out what the
sum of those three digits are.
So in this case, 6 plus
6 is 12, plus 6 is 18.
So were I to add them, I would
get 18 as a total.
And then I'm going to divide
666 by that total.
By 18.
And that equals, so if I put in
666, and then divide that
by 18, it equals 37.
OK, so you happened to pick 6.
Three 6's divided by the sum of
the 6's equals there's 37.
And the reason this counts as
a number trick is before we
started, I predicted that
the total would be 37.
In fact, this is the video,
unsurprisingly, about 37.
And that will work for any
number you care to choose.
In fact, I will show
you why that works.
So let's get this out there.
This is getting a bit silly
writing on paper.
We'll get that out of the way.
Ah, marvelous.
OK, so I'll show you
why that works.
Bring this up.
So when you pick any number.
So you pick 6, or let's do 7
instead, let's say, right?
When you write something like
777, what you're actually
doing is that is exactly the
same as 7 times 111.
Or so whatever your one digit
number happens to be, it's
that times 111.
And when you add the three
digits together, what you're
doing there is you're just doing
whatever your digit was
times 3, because there's
going to 3 of them.
So in fact, that bit there where
I divided, in your case,
666 divided by 18, or here I'll
divide 777 by 21, what
I've actually got is 7 times
111 over 7 times 3.
And these cancel out, and you're
left with 111 divided
by 3, which is 37.
So every single time you do it,
it's whatever the number
is times 111 divided
by whatever the
number is times 3.
These cancel out.
It's always 111 divided
by 3, which equals 37.